[موسيقى]
أجنبية والآن أحب سوقًا
[موسيقى] جيدة ،
فهناك مثل هذا الأكل الذي يأكله الجميع
هنا ويستمتعون به
عند وصولك إلى اسطنبول ، سيكون من
الحكمة أن تترك وراءك كل
مفاهيمك وأفكارك المسبقة
عن هذه المدينة العملاقة  هو المكان الذي
يفسح فيه النظام شكلًا من أشكال الفوضى ، ولكن من
تلك الفوضى تأتي تجارب رائعة
[موسيقى]
يبدأ اليوم تحت جسر جالاتا الشهير
لأنه المكان الذي تحدث فيه الحياة كثيرًا
في إسطنبول ، وهنا
إيقاع المدينة تأتي العبارة و
الذهاب إلى الصيادين الذين يمارسون
تجارتهم ويبدو أن الجميع يأكلون الطعام
مرارًا وتكرارًا سوف تسمع
الناس يتحدثون عن القمة ،
فما هي القمة هذه قمة ،
إنها نوع من التقاطع بين
الخبز والمعجنات أه واحد
شكراً جزيلاً لك
حقًا رخيص أقل بقليل من ثلاثة
دولارات ، هذا هو الشيء الأكثر جمالًا من Bagley ،
هذا هو الأكثر جمالًا
عمليًا كما ترون
الآن حتى أنني لن أتبع
قاعدة الخمس ثوان  مع ذلك ،
لكن هذا هو الأكثر
تناسقًا ، فهو جاهز أكثر ، إنه رائع
مع العسل ،
هذه
قمة استثنائية هي صديقك
[موسيقى
] ، غالبًا ما يبدو أن الأتراك يبنيون يومهم بشكل أساسي
حول وجبتهم التالية ، وأنا
لست مختلفًا
عن ذلك  الطريق إلى نيشانت
بسبب تناول العشاء مع أحد
كتاب السيناريو الكوميديين
المشهورين والمحبوبين في تركيا وبروفات الممثلة الذهبية ، أنت تحب
التسوق ، أنت في منطقة
رائعة لأنك في أفضل منطقة ، لذا
فهذه المنطقة التي نحن فيها  من الجيد أن تفعل
نعم بالتأكيد إنه أوروبي أكثر
غربية مع تاريخ في الواقع
لأن هذا المكان هو رمز
للتغريب التركي منذ القرن التاسع عشر وإلى
أين نحن ذاهبون الآن سنذهب إلى
مكان كباب بالفعل مكان كباب
نعم أنت "  إعادة أخذي إلى مكان كباب ،
نعم ، هذا مختلف ، هذا هو
مكان الكباب على طراز نيشانت ، لدينا هذا
الهامش الطويل ، هل سبق لك تذوقه ، لا
أعرف أنه يسمى صحيحًا ، دعنا نسميها
البيتزا التركية ، إنها أساسًا قشرة رقيقة
مع الأرض  اللحم عليه ، إنه وجباتنا
السريعة ، كتاب الوجبات السريعة التركية
، أنا جاهز لذلك ،
ما زلت غير متأكد مما إذا كنت سأذهب لتناول
كباب أو بيتزا ،
لكنني مستعد لأي شيء
[موسيقى]
هذا  مكان ساحر يجعله خاليًا من
البصل لأنه لا يجب أن تشتم رائحة
البصل ولن تستخدمه مطلقًا مع
السكين قبل لا ،
لماذا لا يمكنك فعل ذلك مثل هذا
الزبادي الصالح للشرب الذي يسمونه في
نيويورك ،
هذا
نوع جيد من  جزاء أيضا هو وجبات سريعة صحية
مرحبا بكم في
nishantishay ما يذهل شخصين ثلاث حلويات